let's go to the phones which are really
just an internet voice
server via discord you can find it at
davidpakman.com
slash discord the waiting lobby
is where you go to talk to me let's
start with harper
from south carolina harper from south
carolina you are on the air
right now hi great to talk to you today
likewise so i was wondering
with i don't know have you heard about
kovacs yes
so what are your thoughts on that and do
you think that that's practical
yeah and what in what what specifically
would not be practical
well i i've been thinking about it and i
i was i was
looking into it a little bit and i saw
that it doesn't really
there's still it wasn't requiring the
the uh the richer more developed
countries
to not have not have that priority
that they have with their deals you know
when they gave a hundred or like a
hundred thousand dollars or whatever
or that's not it a billion dollars to
pfizer to get however many doses
they still have those agreements so it's
it's not
actually getting people in less
developed countries
the doses that they need yeah you're not
wrong but here's the thing
soon the wealthier countries are going
to have all the vaccines that there's
demand for it's it's going to happen
relatively soon it'll feel kind of slow
because we're going through it day by
day but in a relatively short period of
time that's going to happen
so the fact that they've committed the
money i don't believe that the actual
distribution is happening any more
slowly because if the requirements that
you're talking about
were in there i think you'd have less
buy-in so
i think that it's a way to get financial
commitments
the vaccines are not getting to poor
countries nearly quickly enough but i
don't think they'd get there any more
quickly if you had the requirements
you're talking about because a lot of
the rich countries would just say yeah
it's not for us and we're not going to
put any money in
do you think there's any way around that
because what's happening in india is
just
disgusting and terrible i don't think
there is i mean
vaccines are starting to get to india
it's not going to help people that are
dying every day right right
now it's not going to help now yeah no i
don't think there's any way around it
unfortunately
darn i was i was really hoping that you
had some miracle solution
no no by no means what's happened
there's no miracle solution coming to
india other than
the numbers are slowing down at least
the growth rates are slowing down
okay that's good yeah that's good i
haven't heard updates since then yeah
all right thanks harper appreciate the
call thank you
all right very good